oh wow it's the slap that shocked
hollywood will smith rushing the stage
to confront chris rock at the oscars
after the comedian made a joke at the
expense of will's wife jada pinkett
smith jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't
wait to see it all right
now will and jada's son jaden as well as
the family's inner circle is reacting to
the controversy
after the moment went viral 23-year-old
jaden tweeted out this message and
that's how we do it while will's fresh
prince of bel air co-star janet hubert
posted to instagram in support of her tv
son writing in part so proud of you yes
there is only so much one can take
sometimes you have to slap back then
there's tiffany haddish a close friend
and former co-star of jada's she told et
this after the show no i'll define
tonight as a success
it was a great night tonight okay what
did you fall i seen a man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
that made me have hope and in true
tippity fashion she made sure to throw
in her thoughts on how jada should thank
will for having her back i just know she
better take care of business when they
get home
because i know i would if my man did
that for me i'm just saying
yellow chris's joke was seemingly
upsetting to the smiths because it was
about jada's hair the red table talk
host lives with alopecia an autoimmune
disease that results in hair loss she's
been vocal about her struggle with the
disorder in the past now at this point i
can only laugh
now y'all know i've been struggling with
alopecia
and
just all of a sudden one day
look at this line right here
look at that
look at that
and so it just showed up like that now
this is gonna be a little bit more
difficult for me to hide
so i thought i'd just share it so y'all
not asking any questions but you know
mama's gonna put some rhinestones in
there
and i'm just gonna make me a little
crown
that's what mama's going to but not
everyone thinks will's strong defense of
his wife was warranted and since deleted
tweets judd apatow said will quote could
have killed chris and his actions were
quote pure out of control rage and
violence the director doubled down on a
radio show monday morning hopefully it
becomes a teachable moment where will
smith can speak to people in an honest
way about why that was not the way to go
then there's john leguizamo who says
will owes chris an apology the
unfortunate incident let's discuss it
what was your reaction
it was like at first you thought oh my
god it's a skit oh my god just wait a
minute there's no punch line wait whoa
it's a punch not a punch line
and you're like oh that's that's really
unfortunate
how did you feel about will speed
you know
i would like the more of a straight
apology
to chris you know
that would have been that would have
been great because i mean i thought
will's performance was amazing and i'm
sorry that he tarnished it with this
behavior you know
i mean we all nobody likes to be made
fun of but you got to have a sense of
humor about yourself can't take yourself
that seriously i mean we're just acting
you know let's just relax we'll
apologize to the academy after the
incident during his acceptance speech
for the best actor honor i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees this is a beautiful moment i'm
not crying for winning an award it's not
it's not about winning an award for me
it's about being able to shine light on
all of the people tim and trevor and
zach
and tsunaya and demi
and anjanu and the entire cast and crew
of king richard but now there's a chance
will could lose that trophy as the
academy looks into whether the slap
violates its rules on monday the
organization told et quote the academy
condemns the actions of mr smith at last
night's show we've officially started a
formal review around the incident and
will explore further action and
consequences in accordance with our
bylaws standards of conduct and
california law